I'm gonna be very protective Kane brown
tops becoming a father I'm gonna let her
do her thing
I just hope she plays basketball that's
all I want basketball softball some kind
of sport et caught up with the dad to be
a while on the red carpet at the 2019
CMT Awards in Nashville Tennessee where
he dished on his fourth number-one
single good is you good as you and I
first wrote it I just fell in love with
it we listed to a probably 15 to 20
times on the bus I wrote it on the road
and just about my wife I was about to
get married and I was just in love I'm
still in love so so they're just a song
saying I need to be as good as year
[Music]
baby I just wanna play girl
you are nominated tonight how does that
feel it feels awesome I love them seeing
two awards because uh it just gives the
fans a chance to interact you know feel
like they're even more a part of
something yeah they're voting for you
so your first award ever was here at the
CMT Awards right was that just a couple
years two years ago I believe yeah who
are you looking forward to performing
tonight who you're gonna see perform
here the hero sign it about there's just
family everybody you know everybody gets
up on the stage
[Music]